le 19 mars sera célébrée pour la
première fois la journée nationale du
souvenir et du recueillement à la
mémoire des victimes civiles et
militaires de la guerre d'algérie et des
combats en tunisie et au maroc une
journée instituée par la loi du 6
décembre 2012 qui ne fait pas d'ailleurs
forcément l'unanimité bonsoir à
jean-girard épaules mais rien bonsoir à
tous les deux vous êtes président vice
président de la fnaca sur magny les
hameaux dans le département des yvelines
tout d'abord cette date du 19 mars qui
correspond en fait au cessez le feu donc
de cette guerre en algérie
vous en êtes satisfait de cette date
auparavant c'était c'était le 5 décembre
c'était jacques chirac qui avait décidé
de cette manne et 5 décembre qui ne
correspondaient finalement à pas
grand-chose pour grand chose ni aucune
faille historique sur cette date du
solde des cendres est donc le fait que
ce soit le 19 mars au delà du symbole
c'est un moment tu vas être plus
important c'est un moment qui est fort
quand même
le 18 les accords d'evian son signée le
19 le général de gaulle quand même un
personnage
arrêtons les combats le 19 à midi
cessez le feu de la guerre d'algérie
crois que c'est quand même une date
importante comparé les gens chantent pas
d'accord bien sûr bien je suis re après
cette date qu'il y a eu des morts et en
ce moment il ya un problème en tout cas
pour les personnes qui dénoncent cette
date du 19 mars on peut citer par
exemple samedi une cinquantaine de
harkis qui se sont rassemblés à
montpellier devant la préfecture ils
demandent l'abrogation de la loi
justement parce que l'état français
c'est ce qu'ils ont revendiqué à ce
moment là ce week end est responsable et
coupable du génocide de plus de 150000
harkis et leurs familles après le 19
mars 62
donc il faudrait que la date change
encore une fois non le mélange braga ce
moment là même à son on peut très bien
qu'ils viennent nous rejoindre et
comprennent le 19 mars pour eux aussi
bien sûr après tout les conflits vous
avez pu vous prenez longue novembre il
n'y a pas longtemps j'ai lu un article
tuer un livre surtout les mémoires ça il
ya eu jeunes c'est combien de morts
après le 11 novembre et des gens qui
étaient aussi contre longues jambes qui
voulait que ça soit le 16 décembre à ce
que j'évoquais requis au cica
des politiques qui s'engage donc à nice
par exemple conseil général l'ump qui
est interpellé choqué par cette date qui
ne se joindra pas aux différentes
commémorations peut-être vous entendre
sur cette question les morts quelle que
soit l époque et que je trouve assez
stérile de polémiquer
le 19 mars ça s'est arrêté bien sûr il
ya eu à nouveau et il faudrait se
demander de la fota qui n'est pas
spécialement de l'état ce sont les
hommes qui après ont continué à faire
quelques exactions
bon on a fini j'allais lire le conflit
on n'est pas dans la revanche le 19 mars
est une date où on commémore ce n'est
pas une dame de victoire n'empêche quand
on part on commémore et on se souvient
c'est la seule chose qui nous intéresse
j'ai juste serre permet tait géo lire
juste quelques lignes qui a été fait par
le sénateur ump alain houpert et qui lui
dit explique pourquoi j'ai voté pour 19
mars
c'est donc opposition il dit ces hommes
qui ont combattu en afrique du nord sont
de la génération de mon père ils ont été
mobilisés pour faire une guerre qui a
commencé à la toussaint rouge et qui
s'est terminé par un cessez-le-feu le 19
mars 1962
ils ont été envoyés de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée la peur au ventre pour
un avenir lointain un certain 27500 ne
sont pas revenus
ils ont tous donné leur vie leur
jeunesse pour une guerre qui n'avait pas
de nom je pense bien entendu aux morts
aux blessés et surtout aux veuves et aux
orphelins à l'ash à l'absence la chaise
vide le soir autour de la table
familiale à la douleur cette plaie a du
mal à se cicatriser
mais pour faire le deuil il faut une
reconnaissance un lieu une date une
tombe
je proviens la suite c'est surtout le
principal c'est la légitimité de sa
culotte du 19 mars ont des paroles qui
retranscrit zain est vrai
et ces sénateurs ump 1 c'est lyon dans
chaque fois on le dit bien pour nous le
19 mars ce n'est pas la fête
c'est simplement une journée maintenant
les parents qui ont eu un des leurs qui
est tombé en un fn ont quand même
attendu plus de 50 ans pour avoir une
date officielle
une journée nationale pour rendre
hommage à ces hommes ces femmes ces
enfants aussi qui sont tombés en algérie
et puis il a fallu attendre 1999 pour
reconnaître aussi les opérations un
militaire un terminal 62 est absolument
s'étaient reconnus en 2000 comme guerre
d'algérie entre nous on était partis moi
je suis papillon 58
on ne s'était pas la guerre on partait
pour maintien de l'ordre dans la vie de
compris que le maintien de l'ordre
on va voir quelques images d'une
exposition pendant que nous continuons à
discuter c'est un mort passé la fnaca
qu'il organisait également nos vins en
afrique du nord de 1954 à 1962 avec des
témoignages vous avez fait cette guerre
d'algérie vous aviez ventes en une
vingtaine d'années au silence est parti
sur cette guerre
on peut peut-être revenir sur ce sur ce
moment où vous avez tout simplement
après qu'il fallait partir oui je m'en
rappelle je suis parti le 1er juillet 58
et j'ai fait mes classes à table après
on a été incorporé en algérie au 13e
régiment de dragons parachutistes et à
cette époque-là déjà les parents ya
beaucoup de gens qui voulaient pas
partir les voies étaient occupés à la
gare de lyon
les gens se couchait sur les voies ou
voulait partir et je me rappelle quand
on est je suis parti de tarbes
on ne porte pas qu'on puisse qui est du
débordement on était dans une haie de
crs pour nous emmener jusqu'au bateau ça
ça c'est des choses qui restent et
lorsque vous êtes parti lorsque vous
êtes arrivé en situation vous avez
découvert sur place et bien
enfin moi je suis parti plus tard contre
puisque j'ai été incorporé en 1960 en
septembre je ne suis parti en algérie
qu'en novembre 61 donc quelques mois
avant cessez-le-feu
j'avoue que je me souviens plus très
bien si j'étais très inquiet mais je
sais que mes parents l'étaient
ce qui inquiétait surtout les autorités
s'étaient les tentatives de désertion
vivant qui voulait pas y aller même à la
fin et on était effectivement très
surveillée pour être sûr qu'on monte
bien dans le bateau déjà dans le camp
sacs marqués dans le bateau pour
rejoindre l'algérie 19 mars 1962 au
moment du cessez-le-feu
vous êtes ou vous la prenez comment moi
je suis dans les aurès je suis à risque
c'est-à-dire au sud de batna
on l'apprend par les gens qui défilent
et les femmes qui font des youyous vous
la prenez le jour même 19 mars
je sais plus je ne sais plus vraiment
j'avais repris mon travail j'étais ado
est revenu en cours j'étais revenu
puisque je suis revenu dans 61 et bien
sûr j'étais soulagé un même jamais
encore dé la famille qui était en
algérie jamais admis beau frère et tout
le monde était bien soulagé de dire ouf
malheureusement comme vous l'a dit il ya
eu après celle atlab bien sûr il ya eu
des morts il ya eu des blessés mais tous
ces gens qui sont ont été blessés qui
sont morts on les a jamais oublié on les
a avec nous ils sont ce qu'ils font
partie de l'ue 19 mars pour nous on ne
fait aucune différence
aucune c'est à des combattants comme
nous croyez moi que si j'avais pu éviter
d'avion de l'algérie j'aurais été un
parce qu'on a fait la guerre pourquoi
quand on voit ce qui se passe maintenant
il commettait deux maillons plus de ça
avec paul et pilot deux camarades ont
fait un devoir de mémoire dans les
classes qui marche très très bien et les
élèves les enfants sont vraiment
formidables même le monde enseignant
nous aide
y'a pas longtemps il ya un gamin qui
nous anime et pourquoi êtes vous
retournez pas en syrie
j'ai dit tu sais maintenant on a pu
l'agepi espérons que la série va
s'arranger quand on voit on essaye on
essaye nous avec le peu de moyens qu'on
a avec les gamins de rester le plus
honnête possible et puis leur montrer le
le moins de choses possibles qui les
frappe
mais quand ils disent là c'est pourtant
une maison il n'y a plus rien ben oui
oui que la j'entendais là il ya deux
jours là le ce qu'il parlait sur la
syrie en deux ans de temps ils sont ils
ont entre 70 mille cent mille morts où
ça va s'arrêter
merci à vous d'être venu je rappelle
cette date du 19 mars demain cette
commémoration à magny les hameaux ce
sera vers 18h 18h30
et puis il y aura également à la
verrière une commémoration avec
l'antenne locale de la fnaca le maire
alain jaj qui donne rendez vous à partir
de 10h30 on voit des images de la
commémoration de l'an dernier qui
n'était pas donc le 19 mars puisque et
maintenant c'est officiel ce sera cette
date là la date du cessez le feu qui est
retenue rendez-vous à 10h30 pour la
verrière au cimetière pour le
fleurissement du monument aux morts et
puis également à magny les hameaux et
dans de nombreuses communes du
département merci à tous les deux avant
de passer aux sports comme chaque lundi
nous restons à magny les hameaux
quelques instants magny les hameaux une
salle des festivités va être construite
avant la fin de cette année la première
pierre a été posée ce samedi le bâtiment
sera réalisé les meilleurs jury terme en
en bois clair cambier et patrick jacques
de dixmude pour les images la première
pierre est posée un être tout juste
planté voici les premiers signes du
nouveau chantier de magny les hameaux
difficile encore de l'imaginer mais
d'ici la fin de l'année une salle de
festivités de 500 m² occupera cet espace
nous avons choisi d'avoir une salle de
festivités donc assez grande déjà 200
personnes assises ou 260 personnes
debout et puis qu'ils soient localisés
dans un espace ici le pôle anctil qui
est un lieu de loisirs avec le centre de
loisirs ici les tennis couverts le
terrain de foot et ce lieu de loisirs un
petit peu excentré par rapport aux zones
habitées bénéficient de parking de
manière assez importante et du coup et
en même temps un paysage autour sur la
forêt qui est qui est assez assez
magistrale et on aura donc d'ailleurs
une terrasse qui sortira de cette salle
de festivités pour les tec un lieu de
convivialité conçu entièrement en bois
une volonté des architectes pour
s'effacer dans le paysage l'idée d'un
peu du projet c'était de faire une
architecture assez monolithique où on
traite en fait les cinq façade avec un
matériau unique et essayer d'échapper un
peu à tous les codes architecturaux qui
sont le traitement du pied de la façade
et de lui du toit et on pensait aussi
qu' avec le recul que l'on avait su et
les vues qui s'était dégagée sur notre
équipement il était très important de
traiter la toiture donc pour accentuer
ce coteau mode monolithique on arrête
décidé de retourner le bardage bois en
toiture et de traiter en fait cet
équipement commun comme un objet comme
une statue comme une structure
ce projet lancé il y a deux ans est une
initiative de l'ancien maire de magny
les hameaux
jamais loin de son successeur il suit
l'évolution des réalisations que je fais
de sa part c'est que
il est en parfaite harmonie donc avec
donc ce qui était fait complètement
d'accord
est on encore 15 objectifs dont quatre
tirs
qui doit lui poursuivre et ça va être
ses missions tout simplement je serai là
moi donc aussi bien évidemment donc
observer un petit espace
ce que j'ai quand même donc quand même
pas mal de connaissances du registre
hoffman et l'hérault évidemment la ville
a profité des fonds de concours de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour financer
cette salle des festivités un apport de
350000 euros pour un budget total de 1,3
million